naturally optimistic but uh you know
again we'll take it day by day and just
do whatever we can to help remedy this
situation i got his back through
everything so he knows at the end of the
day if he if if there's ever a wonder of
you know he's lost a teammate or
something because of all this coming out
like he knows where i stand i care about
aaron rodgers
from a friend perspective
whatever he wants to do whatever the
situation that comes out i will never
hold any grudge against him
that is my friend that is someone that i
have appreciated and he has done a lot
for this organization and a lot for me
as an individual
now as a teammate i would be
idiotic to say that i don't want the mvp
back
obviously me and aaron we got a good
relationship
talked to him
probably a week before i got out here so
yeah whatever the circumstance may be
come season
just do my best to be ready for myself
for the team and for everybody here
matt laflore devonte adams david
bachtiari jordan love all from this week
at the packers mandatory mini camp it
was the story of the week it's been the
biggest story in the sport aaron rodgers
what's next in this quarterback drama
he either will show up for training camp
or he won't he'll either hold out he'll
retire or he'll be there in the interim
we've got the packers shareholder
meeting
which could get interesting that's when
fans slash owners of the team show up to
hear guys like mark murphy talk about
big issues with the team and whether or
not aaron rodgers going to play for the
team is going to be one of the issues
and i'm sure aaron enjoys that miles
what what does your own personal crystal
ball tell you
is going to happen next for aaron
rodgers and the packers
i just i feel like he'll be back in the
we'll be talking in august about how you
know aaron rodgers will be saying well
things were taken out of context
it will have like a russell wilson type
press conference where it's going to be
something like you know my issues are
not with my teammates i love my
teammates the same stuff he said when he
was talking with kenny mayne you know a
few weeks ago on sportscenter and then
he'll go out he'll play the season and
then we'll be doing the same thing next
year because i i don't
i don't know how this gets resolved in
any other way unless he just says i'm
not doing this i'm going to retire and i
don't know i don't see him sort of
giving up a year of his prime especially
for a team that's gone 26 and six over
the last couple of years in the regular
season they've made it to two straight
nfc championship games i mean i just
there's still a good chance that the
packers are gonna be really really good
this year especially if he plays and he
plays well which i mean if he's playing
he's probably gonna play well that's how
good he is so i don't know i think he'll
be there at training camp i do
i was kicking around some ideas this
week and i don't think this is a
realistic possibility or a strong
possibility i think it's realistic
enough to mention it
we had an idea from peter king
that the packers and aaron rodgers
should agree that he'll play with them
for one more year and they'll trade him
after this season so hey come back one
more year and then we'll give you what
you want
another thing they could do
if he's determined to never play again
for them
one agreement they could reach is okay
you retire
you never play again for anyone
and you don't have to pay us back the 23
million dollars in signing bonus money
that you haven't earned washington did
that with deion sanders
back in 2001 when he decided he did not
want to play for marty schottenheimer
one year after getting his signing bonus
so he retired
they didn't make him pay it back then
they let him keep playing a couple of
years later which was kind of odd marty
was gone which was one of the reasons
why daniel schneider was okay with it
but that's a possibility as well yeah
i'm just you can't rule out anything
because it seems like all the
brainstorming you do it's the thing you
didn't think of that ultimately happens
but that's a possibility if he he would
get the jeopardy job i'm done okay fine
aaron you never come back you never play
for anyone we're not gonna make you pay
the money back as long as you don't play
for anyone you try to play for somebody
else you owe us the 23 million dollars
period uh that's a possibility because i
think the packers
don't want to go through the brett favre
thing again i think that's one of the
issues here they don't want aaron
rodgers playing for somebody else
playing well and making them look bad
right and if you're the packers of
course you don't want that because
frankly i think at this point in aaron
rodgers career he's better than brett
favre was at that point in his career
although you could say that brett favre
had one of the best seasons of his
career with the vikings you know when
and i'm sure you remember that very well
mike uh when you know he was at the tail
end of his career there but i i just
i feel like if you're aaron rodgers
he always
struck me as this hyper competitive
person
and if you're coming off a season where
you just want the mvp
and you're still you know at like the
height of your powers as a quarterback
i don't know that i would want to give
that up i don't know that i would want
to like give up
the chance to be a two-time super bowl
champion instead of just a one-time
super bowl champion you know like
he always has just struck me as that
kind of guy that he doesn't necessarily
need football and like tom brady seems
to need football like he needs oxygen i
don't know that there are too many
people that are at that particular level
but aaron rodgers he's hyper competitive
right like it still loves this game and
you think he loves being really good at
it and i think he loves being the kind
of petty person that says all right you
know you want to do this well i'm going
to do this and i'm going to stick it in
your eye like i just i don't see him not
playing football ever again i i can't
see that and maybe it's because i just
want to keep seeing him play i don't
know
i agree with you and you know people say
oh you just don't want him to play this
year it's like no i wanted to show up
and play in green bay i want a good
story and there's no story better than
the drama that we would have all year
long because it's not like aaron rodgers
will
set it down and never mention it
he'll he won't be able to help himself
just like he wasn't able to help himself
when he was trying to not call me out by
name four years ago there will be
occasions where
he he lets it known that that he still
has issues and you know i think he's
decided that the front office is the
impediment to him adding to his legacy
that they're not making the right moves
they're not putting the right players
around him you know when they had an
opportunity to get a receiver what did
they do they drafted a quarterback it's
a these guys are never going to figure
it out the way that they should figure
it out and they're not listening to me
they act like i just work here and he
wants to go somewhere like tom brady is
where they they not only appreciate him
as a player but they welcome his input
as kind of a quasi gm and we're going to
see more and more quarterbacks get that
power
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports